in a far away land called
washington heights say it so it doesn't
disappear
washington heights lin i feel like i
have to say
mindy siong because you're so immortal
[ __ ]
i'm dominican i can't even put into
words
how much this film means to me there
were you know there was a scene in the
first 10 minutes
of fried sausage and cheese of sachi
chong con queso frito and i was like
yo this is gonna be in the movies we
made it
we made it lin so i had to know my first
question to you is you know
what was the process like how did you
pick and choose what was gonna make it
on camera
oh well i mean that was a many year
process first of all i love that you
zeroed in on that
because john m chu is like his food porn
is unequaled from crazy rich asians to
our movie like the dinner scene
like forget it like the crackers in the
guava like i had pika i was like wow
i know i know um but you know it was it
was a long process
beginning with kiara my brilliant
co-writer who really kind of
smartly updated um the show you know
this is a show that that
existed in 2008 and um the world has
changed a little bit and and it's in big
ways in little ways like
one like gentrification has happened
like there is already the fancy dry
cleaner
on the block it's not like it's coming
in from the outside like it's here um
and and and then sort of the other thing
is um
i don't know i just think she's so
brilliantly just kind of
um centered our neighborhood from a
place of love i think
it's so rare for us to center ourselves
and with joy
and love and affection and i think
that's in every frame of this movie and
um and she and john did that brilliantly
oh my god you guys nailed it and you're
right i mean because this is in 2008 and
there's so many businesses that aren't
there anymore you grew up in inwood
dickman area i have family on 163rd and
broadway
wanted to know what was it like going
back to highbridge pool which is so
iconic um why was it so special shooting
96 000 there for me
when i was a kid that was just the most
chlorinated pool in the history
you come out slightly lighter than you
went in um and
it's but like it's where we would go
swim in the summers and
it's uh again i have to credit john for
kind of always finding the most
cinematic approach
to every moment like he was on a
location scout with kiara
and saw this enormous pool and was like
96
000. and you know in the script it was
on a city block
but john says like no we're going full
bust b berkeley
mgm musical uh in hybrid park and
and i think one of the location managers
told me this is the first movie that's
ever shot here which is
wild to me to find an area of manhattan
that has
not been at least in an episode of law
order um
and and you know we've combed every
block of the thing
um but you know it's so it was so joyous
to
have these songs that are love letter to
the neighborhood being sung
in the neighborhood to be on 175th
street and singing look at the fireworks
to put abuela claudia in the 190th
street one tunnel
um which is so washington heights like
only in washington heights do you have
to walk through a mountain for a mile
to get to the train um and and just
to be able to honor the neighborhood um
with this show that's a love letter to
it
it's it really is a love letter even j
hood wright park i was like wow this is
so
wild lynn and when you walk through the
heights you know it's so funny this is a
musical because walking through
washington heights is like a musical
there's music everywhere
my mom says you know american america
runs on duncan our people
run on music and i noticed that you
mentioned juan luis guerra
in the film which a lot of people don't
know is kind of like our beyonce
and he has this if beyonce and bob dylan
were the same
like it's exactly that and um
grew up adoring his music it won't be
long now is like me doing my best
impression of a juan ruiz
like horn chart um and
and so yeah it really is a love letter
to that i'm so glad you brought up j
hood wright park
you know i i walk with my i play with my
kids in that park all the time
and i remember when they started
rehearsing when you're home
which by the way i wrote after my third
date with vanessa who would become
my wife so it's really the story of us
falling in love with that song
and i remember you know i lived not far
from there and i said honey i know
you're at work but like you have to get
over here and see what they're doing
and she uh she she sort of raced
over and it's very hard to tell the
story without crying
and she looked and she said that's my
grandmother's building
and i said yeah and she goes my
grandmother's building is gonna be in
the movie
like it was like that like every day um
just like these like little like sort of
moments where you realize how many
layers of your lived experience are
gonna be
reflected in this film honestly it makes
me cry too like i
even just hearing juan luis get his name
like i was telling you he has this song
called
um visa paron sueno which reminds me of
the story of like in the heights and i
was wondering like
how you got the inspo you know for the
music and how you mix
all the genres that come from our
countries merengue bachata
salsa and you just beautifully melted it
together
and told the story it's so incredible
and you know for
like you were saying we've seen so many
movies take place in manhattan but we
haven't we rarely get to see
this part of the neighborhood for a lot
of people this is going to be their
first movie going into theaters
so why is a movie going experience so
important for this film and what did
going to the movies mean to you growing
up
well it's it's important because john m
chu dreamed big like in at every turn he
just was like
you know he said these are everyday
characters that we know and we can
consider family but their dreams are
massive
and again like we're so used to as
latino creators being like ibendital
give us three million and we'll make it
the indie version and it'll be okay and
like john was like
no this is a big movie
like we need we need them to dance up
the side of the building
um you know it's he just dreamed so big
for us and so
i think the biggest screen you can find
it on while like still feeling safe
like again your safety is paramount and
i think that what i'm excited about is i
think theaters are opening up again and
people are feeling safe going to the
movies again
and like it's there for you to then go
watch that scene again
when you get home um that scene you
loved from the big screen version so
um and then there's just like a million
easter eggs to
the stage version and and so many other
things there's a little hamilton
easter egg in there like it's it's just
so
much um that it'll benefit from repeated
viewings but yeah
i you know i can't wait to see this
thing at the united palace on 175th
street that has been my dream
uh for as long as this thing has been a
movie um
to to watch it in our great old movie
house pop the great at the crack of dawn
sing while i write down the awning
hey y'all good morning i literally got
chills
watching the film and there are moments
in the film like where your character
is saying things like [ __ ] at the [ __ ]
at that and i was like
i can't believe this is being
represented on a big screen like it
literally is
unbelievable to me wanted to know like
did you have moments like that while you
were filming or when you watched the
film back where you were just like
wow i can't believe this is being
represented on the
on the big screen yeah for sure yeah i
mean like
but like a lot of some of those moments
like i just like did on the spot
like because that was just something i
would say or some you know like
that kind of thing you know um or like
kiara
kiara had it written and i was like
right i would like read it and be like
yo that is
crazy like that is definitely something
we would say there or whatever like
you know it was it was dope to like
to to to be in like a uh
be in a piece where like the vernacular
was so familiar to
the one i grew up with you know like but
people are doing that
yo what's good like you know and the
music and the pulse feels like music i
grew up listening to and you know what
i'm saying like
that that for me um that for me was
uh was one of the best parts of doing
this movie because
you know like people ask me they're like
yo how did you prepare for this room
like prepare
life prepared me for this role like you
didn't
you're not listening to everybody
everybody sounds like they come from our
neighborhood
you know we all you know and and um that
that is what uh you know that that's
that's
that's the that was the best part about
doing this film man it just felt like
every single day number one we got to
shoot
at home i was home i was in new york you
know shooting
and you know my mom's in this movie my
sister's in this movie like
you know like they don't get any more uh
authentic than that
it's wild man and you know a lot of
people don't know you're puerto rican
but a lot of people don't know that
dominicans and puerto ricans actually
have different accents so it's curious
did you what did you do to sort of bring
that dominican accent out did you
probably i grew up around a lot of
dominicans you know
i i so yeah you know
you can't the dominican accent
especially in spanish is not the same
as as puerto ricans and then what's
crazy is that new york in spanish
is different from puerto ricans on the
island right
that that's what people don't understand
either
you know i mean it's so intricate right
like puerto ricans who grew up in puerto
rico speak different spanish
than puerto ricans in new york right and
um and as do dominicans
uh you know uh and the dominicans in my
neighborhood obviously the dialect was
very different from puerto ricans so it
was like
just remembering that remembering those
inflections and remembering like you
know i had one of my boys
he was one of my closest friends in high
school my boy luciano who i like just
from i used to remember tattoo tattoo
like like it's almost like
a song yeah you know what i'm saying
yeah and people don't realize
too that we we abbreviate everything so
instead of saying hola
estas yeah yeah yeah
right i also want it you know it's funny
that
it's just wild that you have this part
and i can't wait for the world to see
you in it i know that um lynn saw you at
the kennedy center
you know i'm sure you've been asked this
and he wanted you to play it but john
the director really wanted
untapped talent but you guys went to
breakfast cried over breakfast burritos
what did you say to him that
you think made him think this guy we
need this guy in this part
i just told him my story man i think it
was really just like
so drama you know we just shared stories
and and we had so much in common
even though we came from totally
different places and totally different
cultures you know grew up
in totally different cultures like it
would there was still this um
there was this common ground where it
was just like yo it was hard
and um and i think you know how we got
emotional where you know where it was
you know i think where it landed for
both of us was that like
we were both sitting in this in this you
know at this breakfast spot
with the opportunity that we both have
you know him being able to direct the
film and
me even being considered for it like and
how far we've come
after sharing each other's stories and i
think that is what got us emotional like
yo man like
you know we're here and how much family
means to both of us and you know we were
just sharing he was sharing about his
family's restaurant and how long it's
been open
and you know when i was talking about my
mom and my my you know my
relationship with my father and and and
the dynamic of that and like you know
and growing up with two siblings and
what that was like and growing up in the
hood and just like
in my journey just my journey and like
you know
how it was just i just didn't even think
i would have a college to go to you know
and
and um it was just like miracle after
miracle angel at the angel
in my life you know so i think that
that's that's that's what con
connected us you know it was like
humanity it's just us connecting us to
human beings and being like yo i feel
you
i love that ah one of the one of the
scenes that got me really excited was
the scene at high bridge pool which is
so iconic and a lot of people don't know
how iconic that pool is but what was it
like shooting that scene
and just being there on set yo that
scene was wild because it was cold
that day it was cold it was rainy and it
was great
thank god for vfx because let me tell
you
that water was freezing breathing but
like
but that was one of those moments where
like someone was like someone asked me
that the day like what was one of the
most special moments on set something
like
you know one of the most special day
shooting and i said
like when we did 96 000 and it was cold
and rainy and like you know everybody
was freezing but
you know the dance is in the water yo
like john got in the water took shirt
off down the water was with his ipad and
like
just in the mix with everybody and i was
just like
watching this right like it wasn't my
turn yet
to get in there and i'm just like
standing back like yo this is like
this is next level our director is in
the water where everybody just in the
mix with his
ipad doing his thing and i was just like
yo this is what's up
and um and i remember like right before
we were going to shoot that big sequence
that
made it into the commercial the 96 000.
everybody splashes the water and
everybody um
everyone was freezing and they were like
and i was just like we would suck let's
go this is
culture let's go this is for the culture
and and you could everybody was yelling
at the top of their lungs and it was
almost like you could feel this
electricity
all around the pool wow and then they
and then john
john always counts down three two one
before he calls action and he's like
three everybody yeah three
yeah let's go let's three two one
action oh and everybody just splashed in
the water and i was just like yo this is
crazy for a lot of people this is gonna
be the first movie they might see in
theaters
why is a movie going experience so
important to this film
and and why was going to the movie so
important to you in your life
we made it for the movies like that's
how it's shot for the fit for the movie
theater it's
the sound alex lackamore our music
supervisor just sent
me um a video of him listening to the
music in dolby
like he was just you know like this was
made
for the movies and you know you can
watch it at home but
there's nothing like you know there's
nothing like seeing this
um there's nothing like like like
experiencing this the way
the way it's intended to be experienced
right in the in the cinema
and um and that's why i encourage people
you know if you can do it safely yo go
go
to the theater go see this in the movie
theater do not
let your first experience be on hbo max
and look
yes it'll be fine there it'll be totally
fine and people have tons of amazing tvs
like or sometimes people you know people
can't get to the theater and that's
that's okay but if you can we do your
best
to like make that your first experience
watching it you know and
um you know and i think i think um
like that going to the movies as a kid
for me that was like a
thing that was you know even like even
as a teenager right when you're going on
a date you going to the movies
especially if you ain't got a lot of
bread you're like hold on let me save up
a little bit
together this little ticket get me this
ticket right i got enough of popcorn and
a coke
make sure if she get hungry and little
chicken tenders with some
fries or whatever depending on where we
go if we go to amc's that's
nicer than the local theater you know
what i'm saying so
it's just you know you it's
it was the movie was that was you know
it was it was an event
it was always an event going to the to
to the theater
you know and and um and i think that's
something that is so sacred and it's
like
you know it's there's something special
about going to this place where it's
like all the lights go down and you're
there for that singular experience right
and it's like hopefully nobody's on
their phone right no one's distracted
when
it's just a group of people focused on
this one thing and it's that story
whatever's playing on that big screen
like right like and that
that to me is special that to me is
connection
right even though even if people don't
say anything to each other they're
laughing at the same things you hear
you know three people in the road
sniffling at the same sad moment
that's connection right and i think
these are the moments that
we yearn for right especially after what
we've been through as
as a you know not just a country but
on a global scale it's like yo
let's get out let's get to the movies
let's get to the theater let's go to
shows
you know when the artists get back on
tour when we get back on tour let's go
let's
come on you know i think that's because
it's human connection man that's what
that's what's most special i think about
life is like
connections life experiences and
relationships
yo he should ask her out right now hey
something on your chart
the way you captured the essence of our
culture
and the beauty of of the heights just
meant so much to me even seeing a shot
of fried sausage and cheese was
yes it made me emotional i was like
sachi chunko queso frito is gonna be in
a movie
my mom's gonna die thank you so much i
feel like you went from crazy rich
asians to
crazy poor latinos
you know when you watch this film you
very much see lynn's
musical style but you see your style too
and i feel like your experience in music
videos really shines through here and
and both styles just
mix together so well so i wanted to know
what was the pre-production process like
in figuring out how to merge both of
your styles and bringing this story to
the big screen
yeah i mean i think we embraced that we
were both storytellers i mean it's her
voice a lot of the times and i spent a
lot of time with her figuring out
where's the source like why does why do
musicals
exist it's not because it's a
performance it's because it comes from a
truthful place when words aren't enough
and we had to pick a cast that could um
ebb and flow between dialogue and music
and dance so effortlessly you didn't
even know they were crossing over
and that they understand that in order
to express a moment that it had to come
from
that place so it was a lot of hey let's
make this together i'm not going to
paint a picture and let's just do that
it's all right anthony what's that what
does it feel like right now what is it
will you express it here and then lin
being like i got a lyric for that and
let's use
so the song will go into that song and
then me saying okay well i can shoot it
in this way to help express that
it was all of us talking all the time
you nailed it you know you mentioned
obviously anthony and the cast and what
i love about you is you love working
with untapped talent thank you for
giving us henry golding
but i you know tell me about that
breakfast you had with anthony
that tell me about what he said to you
that you were just like
man this is the guy for this part he
just told me his story about what it
means to struggle
i think he told me a story of what it
means to yearn for something to dream
about something but not think that
you're you're worthy of it
that you don't deserve it and that his
teacher came to him and not just his
teacher but many people along the way
kept saying no you deserve it you belong
here
and i that touched me because i know how
that feels to me growing up in a chinese
restaurant
trying to be a director and not thinking
there is a real path to that but just
trying to believe somehow and you know
that the community the family the people
that
have rested their stories on you that
you have a responsibility to carry that
forward
and that we don't know whether we're
doing is right or wrong because
no one's there to help us and um and and
i just think that we shared that and
and that if we knew we could communicate
that uh
through in the heights through lin's
lyrics through kiara's writing that
that we could speak to a new generation
that was feeling that same thing and
tell them that they're not alone
and it's okay whatever path they're
choosing to be because they're the ones
who are going to define what that road
is
oh it's and it's such a nuanced complex
feeling right like sometimes we
we as first generation we inherit a
dream that we don't even know if we want
um i wanted to talk to you about you
know high bridge pool
it's such an iconic pool i have family
that lives on 163rd and broadway
so you know walk me through all of it i
you know
i've been hearing stories all day about
how you're in the water you have the
i've
you know the ipad what was it like i was
like taking that on it was such a
massive undertaking
it wasn't scripted there at first we um
you know i was getting a real genuine
tour of washington heights from kiara
and we and lynn was showing me the
places where he used to shoot his whole
videos
and and we were getting the you know
their best cafe coleche
and and we're like what's that building
down at the end of that block
uh which is the end of the block of
we're actually shooting and uh
here it's like oh that's that's that's
hybrid cool so so we're like let's go
check it out so we went there and
when you open those doors and you see
those pools i was like i've never seen
this this is
crazy and they're like really i was like
this is incredible
we have to do a number here and we
started as a joke but
kiara and i as we're driving in the van
later we're like
that's not a joke like we have to do
that we have to bring
that esther williams thing here we have
to show that latinos could have been
starring in these old musicals back in
the day and been
just as good and just as beautiful in
all its shapes and colors
and and are the shorts could be
mismatched and the towels can be all
different colors
and it was going to be just as brilliant
and gorgeous and and to me like
that's that's what the whole show is
about so why not do that
and to have ballerinas both men and
women in sneakers and
tattoos like that that cut through all
the
the facade of what a musical is it says
it's the essence of what you're feeling
that is a musical um and so
we had to fight the rain it rained a lot
that day uh the
cold of course uh 500 600
extras uh towels that had to keep them
dry so nobody got hypothermia
kids ages five to eighty years old uh
fire marshals because we had barbecues i
mean it was a massive
massive undertaking it's literally the
coolest thing ever i cannot wait for
people
to see 96 000 on a big screen and
speaking of big screens
you know this is probably the most new
york movie we've seen in a while
why is that important and why is the
movie going experience
so crucial to this film in particular my
favorite thing from hearing feedback is
people saying
this is the most authentically new york
movie i've seen in a long time
because to me i'm like you want to know
why it's because
the the latinx community is new york it
is new york like it's not woody allen
it's it's this neighborhood and i
it's like the biggest compliment and the
biggest like thing that
shows that we did what we need to do
like that life that spirit
that um they treat you like family when
you're shooting on this
street they yell at you like family they
invited my mom who was sitting on the uh
i told her don't move from this stool
and i
went to go shoot the moon i came back
she's upstairs drinking beers with like
the family upstairs like they just
bite her up that that's unity that's
america that's like
real life and uh and so that that was
really um
to share that has been really fun and i
think that movies in general
are really important i love streaming of
course but movies placed in cultural
um change is is undeniable i experienced
it with crazy rich asians
but really for this one i knew that the
details the food the
uh the pattern the clothes all was
really important
um allowing the audience to catch up to
our characters about
you know you don't have to put a
subtitle for everything just the word is
the word and
and go with it and learn um but in the
end of the day
t and warner brothers that has to
promote a movie with these
the people who look like this in these
shapes and sizes to say
they're worth your time your money um
the effort to go sit in the dark
and learn about them and see them and
celebrate them and and
and and want to be like them after and
look them up after and
look up the music learn how to dance on
youtube salsa like
to me that is the power of a movie that
that changes
stuff um so that's what i'm excited
about john that just
gave me chills and and i know that you
you know you didn't want to celebrate
the success of crazy rich asians i read
a couple of things on the internet about
that i hope that you
you do feel in your heart that this is a
success because it is to me and i can't
wait to see it with my family and i
can't wait for the world to see it i
feel like
finally it's like our turn you know
hearing you talk about the food and that
breakfast
to me we had a huge discussion about
that we've got to squeeze that shot
what's the what's the close-up who's
what kind of food is it like
that means that all the effort the extra
effort that we took that
a lot of people wouldn't understand um
was with worth every minute of that
that's where i get the satisfaction not
the box office
we all had a suenito and when it came to
dreams
we had to keep scraping by my first
question is for you because
for you to tell nina's story a first
generation latinx story i feel like we
rarely get to see those
on screen what was it like for you to
tell that story and how did it make you
think about your own experience and did
you think about your own experience
differently after that most definitely
i'm still processing
thanks to nina nina gave me so many
gifts um
i i came to discover myself in a lot of
different
ways thanks to you know having to delve
into nina's story
and um it really was a time where i like
contextualized a lot about myself and my
upbringing and what it means
um to be first generation latin
americana and be from dominican parents
who
you know my grandma moved to new york
and like my mom you know built built
built her her community
there in the bronx and like ended up
having a business in the bronx right in
the same building that my grandma moved
to
and like that was like our block
experience and
connecting all those dots to what you
know nina's going through and feeling
you know her sense of responsibility
with her community
and going out into the world and taking
her community with her and not just
leaving it behind
um it put into context all the the
sense of like responsibility that i feel
in a way with my family that we all feel
you know um we always want to
put i know cory feels the same way we
always want to put our best foot forward
we want to represent the family we want
to
you know do it for our ancestors we want
to we
understand to some degree the sacrifice
that it's taken for us to
to even have the opportunity to dream
this big and to
and to do things that we've never seen
our family do before um but we also you
know feel the daunting
you know expectation of like even though
you don't have a path to follow
you are the pat created you know and so
um throughout the process of of you know
trying to do my best on my first film
and
and and discovering nina and not messing
this not messing it up
uh i definitely was feeling the same
things that nina's feeling in her story
along with my family while they call me
up and they're like yo
you you dancing are you doing the
rehearsal are you default
no again so it was very you know
very synonymous with what uh what i was
feeling was very synonymous with the
with the feelings that nina feels in in
in the film and in the story god that
just makes you feel like
just so seen and how sometimes we we all
like inherit someone else's dream you
know and you feel like you got to carry
on corey what's so cool about benny and
i know you grew up in harlem
is that he kind of brings this every
man's perspective to the movie i thought
um but i wanted to know did you have to
learn spanish did you have to learn how
to dance merengue for this
well um well i say i said i grew up in
dc
i lived in harlem but i also lived in
the heights
so it was like yeah so like that was
like
um uh a bit of a bit of coming back home
when we when we were shooting um
i did you know have to learn my like you
know little spanish here and there
i tried i see nanos i'm not saying you
know
i tried i did try to do what i could um
but that's also benny's journey too
right like yes he
uh came to the heights and i think when
he was very young
um and and sort of grew up loving and
embracing that community and also
finding
the similarities like he looked that's
that is i love that you
know that you said that he you know it
was sort of looking for those
uh or that he's the sort of every man
because i think he
does sort of bring out the best in all
of us
and he tries to do that with um
obviously with nina
and and uh or just find the best in all
of us and
and in in himself um
he's also like wondering why people are
like going away when when
we this is the best this is it this is
home this is where
we we dream biggest and and our dreams
start and can come true um and just
reminding people of their worth
uh i just love that about benny he's a
hustler he's
he's a go-getter um and he's just full
of life
and i try to live that way as much as i
can
um but yeah yeah yeah it's just an
incredible experience to
to be able to kind of bring him to to
screen in all his
uh three-dimensionality yeah and
you killed it and speaking of full of
life let's talk about this pool scene at
highbridge pool because it's it's so
iconic and i just felt like it was such
an undertaking i want to hear from both
of you
what it was like filming that any
anecdotes you can share
it was crazy well yeah leslie came to
set that day
i was not a part of this number but i
came to set and
was just blown away because i
i got there and john was in the pool
along with
all the dancers freezing i remember
sunny gregory was in there doing his
his all his bone breaking stuff and then
all that breaking it down and john was
in there
it was a very very cold day like it was
you i'll let you tell the story but i
was just i was blown
i'll just say like shout out to first of
all shout out to chris scott and our
incredible
choreography team they they are
they make the dancers in this film make
this film i wish they could be up here
speaking about this
process as much as we as much as we you
know because we had to
we were rehearsing that before we got to
hybrids then we got up there and then it
started raining
it was the coldest day of the year
supposed to be the hottest day of the
year it was the coldest day of the
summer
and but we made it work and like we had
ice cream trucks brought it like we were
just like
living our best lives we had music i
didn't want to take my shirt off because
i was like john you got to take my shirt
off on camera
so i didn't eat i was trying to be on a
diet for like
get tired you held out because it was
towards the end
and then we get to the end and then it
starts raining when we get there they're
like sorry guys we got to wait another
four weeks i'm like
no hold up
then when we finished uh we found him
finished the scene i just remember us
all it was just one of the best days and
then we all went to the trailer
and there was a mcdonald's up there off
of broadway that mcdonald's right there
on that corner
and we all just ordered mcflurries and
like
it's pigged out we just went to town
because we were like oh we're done
this is gonna be one of the first movies
people might be seeing in theaters
why is the movie going experience so
important for this film and what did
going to the movies like mean to you why
was it important for you in your life
oh man it was so important that was like
our family tree
you know um it wasn't every day that we
got to my parents
you know would rill up the family go to
the movies
so when we did get the chance to and get
you know my siblings get a big family we
would it would be a
you know a little a little moment um
and i just think that this movie i'm so
glad that we waited
especially after the year that we've had
i think is exactly what everybody needs
this job of
of just hope and joy and like it's
almost
a vaccine full of hope and joy for
everyone that we all need
um and it's even more timely than before
and
it's uh something to be experienced
together
as a community because that's what our
movie is about uh
even even more so than when you watch it
i love that we're gonna get to watch it
at home but
i think uh you definitely want to see
this movie on the big screen
yeah and it's a blessing to be able to
um to be that film that people come back
to see
you know because again like she said
after everything we've we've been
through this movie has been
a long long long time coming even before
we started shooting so
for people to finally get up there go
see themselves
celebrate the culture and and celebrate
each other
it's exactly what we need and film
making to be able to jolt us back into
to sitting in the theater the lights dim
to disappear into an experience
supported
nothing like it so i can't wait for
people to to experience it
maybe this neighborhood is changing
forever maybe tonight is our last night
together however
i just want to see the whole world
through our eyes there were moments in
the film
where even when everyone's singing a
lavanza right about
grandma claudia where i was like wow i
can't believe this is gonna be on a big
screen at the theater
did you have any moments like that while
you were filming dasha or was there any
like prop
scene or moment where you're like wow i
can't believe this is going to be in
movies
absolutely and it started even at the
rehearsal
honey we gotta connect i like connecting
with all my people okay
well you know even at the moment of
rehearsals there was moments of like
a lot of energy right here a lot of
wow this is this is our music this is
happening
um when we were rehearsing like the big
scenes
it involved everyone and we had to like
incorporate the flags
those were moments that like you can't
explain
the goosebumps and the moments of
wanting to cry because it's it's not
like
even throughout the movie right when we
would watch the trailer like i couldn't
contain myself and just
for some reason the emotion that it
evoked on the screen of like
it's so gratifying and validating and
like it also
it also it also not only
adds to being proud but like
it kind of it kind of wakes you up
and and allows you to understand that
when you have a dream
all it takes is for one person to take a
risk to believe
and it starts with you and from one
little idea
huge things can happen and this is a
huge moment for for
film um it was a huge moment on broadway
but it's a huge moment for film
um it's a huge moment for for
for berlin for the writers for the
actors in it as well
and for me um being in a neighborhood
where
i spend most of my time and growing up
and
seeing the change that has happened um
being able to film there and give that
to the community um was very it was very
satisfying
yeah i don't think people i mean i know
you worked at a medical center in the
bronx so it just must have been
so surreal for you you know your
character works in a salon
i was trying to explain to people i know
a lot of people don't know that people
travel far and wide to have a dominican
person do their hair
um what was it like were you guys in
these salons in the heights where the
people in the background people that
work in the salons can you tell us about
like
filming in the salon well the salon um
was actually
created it was a set it wasn't a real
salon right so
shout out to to the crew and set design
because they were amazing but you know i
think that
for me the inspiration was from my own
experience
in i am dominican i am i grew up in a
salon you know like this
this is culturally something that we're
known for
um and even though the story is not it's
it's in washington heights it's not
based on
dominican is based on the latinx story
of dreaming of gentrification and so on
um and so i i drew inspiration
from my aunts and my mom and my
experience
right but everyone was so supportive and
i think that
it's important to understand that in
this community
um there's a lot of love there's a lot
of pride there's a lot of celebration
um and i for me was important that i
bring that forth in my performance and
that i represent
um being dominican and being proud and
and that you know i mean it might be
noise for some but it's
it's not noise for us it's it's our
background is our
um it's it's our soundtrack
i always say that like i don't i don't
mind
the noise because for me what is noise
is my music
um you know coming from dr where we have
three genres that that
you know are pretty much a country that
has three genres of music that we
created
and you know i i embrace that and i'm
very proud of that and and
being in hollywood and being part of
these huge films
you don't get exposed to that you don't
get to carry that you have to kind of
like
you kind of have to put that away you
know you gotta like put it under the rug
right now that's not what we're looking
for we don't understand it and that's
okay we don't have to understand it
um we just have to connect with it
and that's why my trajectory as an actor
for the last
um almost a decade i've been part of
huge projects that have pushed the dial
forward but have
been impactful in um the industry
um and being part of my first musical
you know as a dancer
singing very insecure i even had moments
where i was sabotaging myself
and not really vocally showing what i
can do
and i'm you know nas i'm being very
very honest and vulnerable because i
think it's important for us to
understand that
you're not only an actor there's a lot
of other things as a woman
as a human being that you bring forth to
these projects that make the character
what it is
and i respect um what kiara
wrote and lynne um put together
alongside
june's uh john's direction but i also
had my own initiative and my own
my own intention and that was that i
have to serve the authenticity right
and i'm not just only uh you know dasha
polanco
advocating for diversity i'm dasha
polanco
dominican immigrant that has had the
opportunity to be part of such
an amazing project alongside
all the pushback and all the obstacles
and all the adversities um
you know it goes to show that one person
can can do as much as they can do you
know and i'm my only limit
right right so so for that for the salon
and for all that i drew and i drew and i
also respected it because it's just not
being a salon girl
you know what i mean there's more to
that 100 and that's what makes me so
happy when people like your cast and i
know you preach this to your children
and like it's just
it really is so inspiring to like watch
you do all these projects that mean so
much to everyone like you were saying
not just dominicans the whole latinx
community
especially in the heights i wanted to
ask you about filming at highbridge pool
because that pool is so iconic and i
don't think a lot of people know about
that so can you talk to us about what it
was like filming there
on and and that number 96 000.
well 96 000 is a is a huge uh record hit
i mean like
it's it's a fave right you know being
there
first of all the weather was not
being nice right it was cold it was
still raining
but being there in that pool being in
hybridge pool
being it was just you had moments for me
that i still have to take a moment to
myself and say wow
like i i was just here you know what i
mean now i'm like you can't
make this this you can't make this up
right
watching the neighborhood watching how
much people were
proud and in support of and you know
they weren't bothered because this was
about
being in the heights right and about
seeing us and they saw us and
people were willing to like even you
know do you need something to drink the
it's just a very warm and welcoming
community
and so even though the number took
so long the dance community i mean the
work that
that they put into to what they do
i mean these are artists that
speak a language with their moves right
and and they were part of this in the
water
but for the same cause for the same
purpose of creating
this story um and bringing it to life
and that you can't really
relive you can't explain it you have to
experience it i mean you had all ages or
all the diaspora
skin tones i mean origins
it's it's a true resemblance of what the
world
and what we should see on tv right where
it's not about
let's check a box it's about let's just
tell a story
yeah and let's connect right nitty and
small ways
little details that tell the world we
are not invisible
this must be so exciting for you because
you were in in the heights
in off-broadway so to to be in this role
from off-broadway to a major motion
picture i wanted to know did you
add anything to abuela claudia
well nas i was in the readings the
workshops
off-broadway broadway and then now the
movie
so if you can imagine it's been quite a
journey
yes the movie has some surprises
that that are just a little a little
different from this
from the play and john's vision
john's cinematic vision i had to kind of
step up to that
that uh enormous
vision that he had you know the way he
broke the fourth wall
and the way he just um
padded that song uh but the feelings
of that song which is a very special
song to me that i personally had to grow
into
because when i started this project i
was playing another role
and then they couldn't find an older
lady to play abuela claudia and they
auditioned me and then
the rest is history but um that's it's a
very special
song and all the the emotions and the
depth
have to be there it doesn't matter
what's going on around you
because there was a lot going around
going on around
me for the movie and what they did
with that number um so you have to stay
and it's very emotional for me uh
because i can relate to some of it
and i brought in all my my my my
aunties and my grand mothers and my
mother and
and all of that there and so so that
it's
packed with emotion you have to be very
very
focused in telling the story
and let the team do whatever they're
going to do around you
i don't know if i'm answering your
question you are i mean
people are going to see things in the
film that they haven't seen before do
you feel like the character has changed
like have you brought in any new stuff
like in all these different iterations
there are some some different some
differences
a slight just very slight differences in
some of the scenes
that i have in the movie just because
it's a movie and you can
you know you can actually sit on a stoop
you know in an actual scoop in a new
york city block
you know and you can um you could go
inside an establishment
because there's a one of the themes of
the movie is the changing neighborhood
you know gentrification and so that's
that's something that's a little
different
from the play right um that i got a
chance to do
and but as far as um i think the
character is the same
it's just the medium of the of the movie
allowed me
to kind of you know expand my wings a
little bit and and kind of
settle in that medium a little bit
better it's just
there's more you can do you know right i
i know how
personal that was to you i'm dominican
and i have family in the heights and
that
that tunnel from the one train on 191st
street is
so it's just so iconic and and i thought
about you because i know you're cuban
and i thought about how you were
probably thinking about your mom while
singing it so it's
it's so cool to hear you to to speak to
all that and i really feel like you
really brought that
in everything um you know for a lot of
people this is going to be their first
time seeing this part of new york
on film and it's going to be it can also
be a lot of people's first time going to
the theater to see it
so why do you think the moviegoing
experience is so important for this film
and what was it
what does going to movies mean to you
like how important was that for you and
your life
i miss going to the movies i that's one
thing that i do
i go i'm a moviegoer during the day when
there's
five people in the theater that's my
favorite time to go to the movies and in
new york
i just walk there and go and that's that
was
one of my maybe favorite things to do
i'm looking forward to doing that and i
hope everyone will see this movie
and in the movies because you have to
see it in the biggest screen you can see
because those musical numbers are huge
it's so important to have the
this diversity of this movie and and to
to have the latino culture be seen
by so many people you know uh just
by everyone in the united states and
abroad
and and to see that we
love our family we love our community
we're funny we're smart we're hard
working
and and to have everybody understand us
a little bit better we're like everyone
else
right you know we have the same issues
we want to
to we're reaching for our dreams
sometimes we get we accomplish them
sometimes we don't
we're trying to you know we came here as
immigrants and we're trying to
to to to have the american dream and
we're working hard
and it's it it just it's it's i'm so
happy that the world is going to see us
me too you know during the musical
number
a lavanza i was like i can't believe
like is gonna be like
in a major in innovation right it really
is just so wild
you know there's a there's a phrase that
nina the character nina says and she
says let me listen to my block and i
wanted to know
in moments of uncertainty or when you
have fear when you're feeling
discouraged what grounds you what brings
you home for some people it's listening
to their block for other people to smell
what is that for you well that's a great
question and i just want to say
kiara alegria i love her writing and she
really brought it
she brought it home for me what grounds
me is
nature and i need to you know i
like even this morning i had a very
quick because i had to be here i had a
very quick stroll
in central park and um
i during covet it's just like i
discovered trees
i'm like i don't know birds
and nature and margaritas too um
because i don't drink but during colvin
it was like you know
um but uh being surrounded by nature
really grounds me do you think this
movie is going to ignite
a movement to save the neighborhood
because gentrification is like a real
thing that's been happening there for
a long time i really hope so
i hope so and and lynn is a champion
of that neighborhood and he's already
saved a few places himself
single-handedly so
i hope so that's it's my wish
this is the moment when you do better
than me because you can see a future
that i can
i wanted to ask you about um first kiara
alegria
because you were actually worked with
her um on a musical called miss you like
hell
so what was it like working with her on
this
and how much input did she have in the
film
did kiara have guerra quiera wrote the
book
literally um quiet is a
magical mystical being
she is you know a soul sister
to me and
i can't say enough about quiet you know
like
she happens to be an amazing
poet writer like she tells the truth
in this funny humorous and yet
very poignant and specific lens
that she brings that um is very heart
opening
i think that um you know i i've been
very lucky
to work with people who who have created
works that are very
open-hearted and jada is
an open-hearted writer she is
she knows how to articulate the open
heart
was there any moment for you on set or
any prop or any scene where you were
just like
wow i can't believe this is going to be
represented on a big screen
yeah all of it um specifically
you know what comes to mind is just you
know the high bridge pool the 96
000 um all those faces and bodies in the
pool
like you know dancing up a storm and
um that's one the image of um
the outside of my salon um
there nelson coates did a
wonderful job of um of replacing
replacing
replicating i'm sorry um an artist
named angulria who um who does the
you know the afro latinas and the
latinas
you know and curlers hugging and
solidarity and having
you know black and brown faces and full
curlers and majesty
and they're you know they're very sort
of yeah that
um to me to see that very centered in a
film was um
incredibly gratifying i i felt the same
way because a lot of people don't know
that people travel far and wide to have
a dominican girl you know blow out their
hair
you know like people just don't know
that stuff
but now people will but let's go back to
high bridge pool
because that pool is so iconic daphne so
what can you
tell us about what those two days were
like filming that number
really fun i mean they were
they were a lot of fun because we were
just getting to
it was at the beginning-ish of of the
shoot
or maybe i remember that wrong it was
the day that we that we were all
working out to get really in good shape
for i remember that much so once we got
over that home
so it was not at the very beginning but
um
i digress it uh it was so inclusive
um it was so it was like a party
every time we were on the set and
what's really incredible is that people
are working
so you can't be loud and all crazy like
really party and yet
that energy was so there uh but when
it's go time it's go time especially
when you're waiting for the sun to come
out and
set up with the shot and then it rains
so we got this kind of
and just the the precision the
implementation of like
excellence like in go time was just
magic amazing it is magic i can't wait
for the world to see that on screen you
know
for a lot of people this is going to be
maybe their first movie that they see in
theaters and
what's exciting to me is that we've seen
a lot of movies take place in new york
right
i don't know if we've really seen this
part of manhattan so can you speak to
that
and and why the movie going experience
is so important
for this film because exactly what you
said you know
new york is a beautiful beautiful city
it is so photogenic and it's so alive
and i know i'm partial
but washington heights specifically
is a gem it's it's the heights
um and the views are spectacular just
the way the light hits you know they
talk about
provence and how the you know the the
the um the impressionists they're french
because of the way the light hits in
france
you know the light hits on washington
heights really nice there are some
serious impressionists up there and
and if this is like a heights
impressionist painting like
the kind of beauty that can be created
when you have an
environment that's so beautiful and
fertile and to celebrate that
um it's so beautifully well said i i
love the way you describe that
there there's a phrase that the
character nina says in the film that
really stuck with me because i have
family that lives on 163rd and broadway
and
she said let me listen to my block and
when the when this
everything goes away it really does
sound like what washington heights
sounds like so i was wondering
what do you do to ground yourself when
you're feeling uncertain about something
and to gain that feeling of home for
some people it's listening to their
block for other people it's a smell
what is that for you
right that's not the right key but you
know i'm not going to sing it just
breathe
breathe you know the way
that yeah um like it is
such just to breathe in and breathe
out the power of that is sacred and
yeah that's all i got for that you know
this pandemic really had us all
slow down and and and really
some of us got to feel in ways that um
i know i you know had to meet another
side of me that really needed to be
patient
and full of hope
you know that that was actually a tool
it wasn't
it wasn't coming you know putting my
head in the sand or anything it was an
actual tool um
and i think this film illustrates how
that works in people's daily lives on
the daily
the best days of my
[Music]
to a couple life days in the life of
what is